vocês já pensaram que dá atenção ao
cartaz poderia mudar suas vidas
eu deixei pensei que sim eu sempre
caminha na escola observa todas as
paredes todos os murais e me procurando
por oportunidades por chance de
descobrir algo novo e no final do
primeiro ano do ensino médio
eu vi esse cartaz que falava sobre a
olimpíada brasileira de neurociências
eu fiquei impressionada neurociências
nem sabia o que era inocente
no primeiro ano do ensino médio então eu
tirei uma foto e resolvi quando chegasse
em casa procurar para saber o que era
nas neurociências e disponível para
alunos de ensino médio
as neurociências é uma área que são
áreas diversas áreas que estudam o
sistema nervoso então com agência
podemos saber como funciona o processo
de mexer o dedinho do pé ou entender
como nós aprendemos a conhecer doenças e
eu fiquei totalmente animada em saber
que eu poderia estudar um pouco mais
sobre isso já que eu era fascinado por
ciências e eu resolvi ainda me engajar e
começar a estudar por conta própria essa
fascinante área ea primeira coisa que eu
comecei a fazer foi desenhado e eu
comecei a dizer neurônios neurônios ou
células nervosas que cor que participam
dessa rede fantástica que é o sistema
nervoso e que eu pude conhecer um pouco
mais
eu começava a desenhar pintar colorir
mas ainda não tinha noção do que a
senhora se eles realmente estudavam e eu
descobrir que o senhor hoje não tem só
aquela fominha e parece uma estrela e
tem o axn o nené que seria esse
prolongamento longo mas ele tem várias
formas que têm o que parece terá tempo
parece uma árvore e eu fiquei nossa não
sei nada e eu comecei também a estudar
as doenças que afetam o sistema nervoso
e os designers autismo e à desordem como
autismo esclerose lateral amiotrófica
e comecei a ficar é que ele é
intensamente emocionada e profundamente
a e sensibilizou bastante como pequenas
alterações e interrelações entre células
podem afetar o organismo inteiro e que
isso pode ocasionar tudo pra família
como prova de vida e também estudei
anatomia como o cérebro é organizada e
descobrir que certas partes do cérebro
parece cavalos marinhos
o vulcão porque é uma área onde se
formam as memórias iniciais e aí eu ia
foi no curso de neurosciência eu
descobri isso para alunos de ensino
médio fiquei nossa hipocampo cavalo
marinho e assim é impressionante
maravilhada com isso e também uma outra
estrutura do cérebro parece um mickey
mouse
eu fiquei igual e que também no dia eu
nossa nunca tinha percebido e também eu
estudei uno falou sobre uma doença que
deixa chamada parkinson é uma doença que
nós perdendo no caso do paciente ele
perde os neurônios dessa área que eu
falei do mickey que homens é falo em uma
área que é bem escurinha que é onde
ficam os neurônios que participam da
iniciação de movimentos que a substância
negra sobre quando a pessoa tem impacto
nessa para essa área fica menos escura o
que mostra perda desses neurônios e com
essa perda essa pessoa tem dificuldade
de movimento então entender como essas
células se organizam e entender que isso
pode ocasionar por ano de doenças e
tentar diagnosticar isso sozinho então
ensino médio procurando livre tentando
descobrir fingir ser médico para
descobrir isso foi incrível
foi muito bom muito interessante uma das
áreas que mais me chamaram a atenção
a competição não é aquela prova a
competição das olimpíadas ineficientes
neurociências não é aquela prova que nós
temos que perguntar e responder
o desafio é uma das provas era a prova
de neuroanatomia que tinha um cérebro de
verdade e temos que identificar com
alfinetes indique qual era aquela área e
descobrir qual era a função
achei louco mas é a primeira prova que
eu fiz você quase todas as questões mas
foi muito interessante porque eles
cortavam é tínhamos várias partes do
cérebro cenário de profundas e tenta
identificar com ela quer a área ou o que
poderia acontecer com uma pessoa se ela
não tivesse funcionando muito bem ou
entender como funciona os processos que
fazem as é mantermos o sono ou guarda
menores
eu participei em 2015 e da olimpíada do
rio de janeiro e conquistou o primeiro
lugar nesta competição e pôde participar
da olimpíada nacional
obrigado a citar da olimpíada nacional e
conquistei o segundo lugar
o primeiro lugar é o que é o
participante que representa o país na
unb no internacional e na época não
deixei
não fiquei satisfeita e queria tentar
mais uma vez para ver se eu conseguia
alcançar o primeiro lugar no ano
seguinte para tentar conhecer outros
jovens entender ou participar de novos
desafios na área de neurociências e
também não só a questão de neurociência
mas também conhecer outras histórias
porque não é só o pessoal daqui que tem
problemas mas também outros países
também teriam problemas ou tem jovens
engajados prontos para descobrir novas
áreas novos conhecimentos criar amizades
e criar laços que durariam para a vida
toda
então eu participei 2016 da unip de
neurociências e eu conquistei o primeiro
lugar novamente me tornando de copiar
rio de janeiro
ligado e participei da olimpíada
brasileira e conquistou o primeiro lugar
poder representar o brasil na dinamarca
[Aplausos]
na época teve problemas com fundos e com
passaporte mas com o apoio de várias
pessoas no brasil eu conseguir tanto
esforço e dedicação e pelo entendimento
das pessoas que isso é importante ela
negou e não me conhecia pessoalmente mas
várias pessoas se engajaram se motivaram
a me ajudar a me realizar esse sonho e
foi assim que foi um dos motivos foi
possível conseguir chegar na dinamarca e
participar da competição internacional
de neurociências foi incrível por
oportunidade quando eu tive contato com
outros jovens que também passaram por
situações como eu teve jogos que nem
conseguiria chegar na olimpíada
internacional para poder participar de
jogos que chegaram atrasadas mas todos
engajados estudando procurando de
conteúdos e animados com vários tipos de
reações diferentes com culturas
diferentes idiomas tinham jovens que não
falam era o nativo de inglês porque a
competição internacional
o idioma oficial inglês jovens que falam
francês e um jovens falavam craniano
então tinham várias drogas e todos
tentam se unir pelo idioma único então
vamos comunicar tentam trocar idéias
trocar histórias num vou falar um pouco
da competição a competição é um pouco
mais complexa do que a do brasil e essa
era uma das cenas da competição que ele
fazia as perguntas oralmente pra todo
mundo que quisesse ver
e nós temos que ver no papel qual é a
resposta certa ea moça recolhidos
papeizinhos enero cientistas
profissionais ficavam sentados
observando todos os participantes e
descobrindo e discutindo as questões por
exemplo dos papéis vizinho a quem
acertou brasil austrália o meia você não
viu seu nome fica lá até essa mas foi
bem desafiador e estava tudo bem
você tem que se concentrar no idioma e
aprendendo ciências inglês mas foi uma
experiência muito enriquecedora mas
também podemos conhecer o tá aqui outra
prova que a prova já matou 60 várias
peças ea gente rodava nas mesas e olhava
lá e tinha um tempinho certo para
descobrir qual é aquela área
olhando o microscópio e excel a 0
aquelas que tinham células dentro do seu
cérebro que você nunca vou falar
estava ali a gente sabe qual era criança
ela é bem desafiador e tinha uma prótese
é uma prova mais tradicional que aí nós
temos que de uns tempos bem rígidos para
responder às questões
mas também podemos inovar zew de
medicina da dinamarca conhecer um pouco
da história da medicina lá entender como
funcionavam as cirurgias que não é
porque eu não tinha nem álcool
então as pessoas abriram às vezes as
pessoas como elas abordadas e aí e
mostrava os equipamentos e depois de
aprender um pouco mais sobre isso então
foi o aquecimento além de desafio foi
cultural também e também ver peças
anatômicas também foi vencedor
achei fantástico eu votei duas fotinhos
eu diria eu ia tiramos muitas fotos e
mais acentuada do tênis e também podemos
participar do fórum de neurociências de
sociedades européias e com esse e outros
jovens né neurocientista no caso a gente
não é exatamente neurocientista mas
somos jovens bem nobre aprendendo
neurociência e com enrico e pude
conhecer alguns jovens brasileiros que
estavam lá na dinamarca apresentando
trabalhos de mestrado doutorado e poder
discutir com eles os trabalhos deles foi
o trabalho de roth foi foi sobre
parkinson
porque eu estava louca pelo mic né e aí
eu comecei a falar sobre o movimento
porque o porquê de tudo mas sim o que eu
mais perguntas do que eu pude aprender
com isso tudo é importante
dá um passo porque se tivesse passado
pelo corredor tivesse ignorado aquele
cartaz
talvez não teria me aprofundado estudo
de neurociências
talvez eu não estaria aqui agora falando
com vocês tentam transmitir uma ideia
nova para vocês mas eu não eu vi aquele
cartaz e mesmo vendo aquele cartaz e
poderia ter deixado a falta de lado e
não ter procurado não tem descobrindo
que era ou depois de ter descobrido
descoberto o que era e neurociência ter
ficado com medo e não tenha estudada por
achar que outras coisas eram mais
importante mas eu agarrei desafio
então eu quero deixar para vocês que o
importante é não deixarmos para depois o
que a gente pode fazer agora
então é sempre bom nós acreditar mas o
que nós temos dentro de nós e dar mais
um passo e seguir seus passos
então eu segui meu passo e assim eu pude
além de crescer por crescer de várias
maneiras eu pude está época incentivar
outras pessoas a também crescer
eu pude com a minha história é tocar o
coração de várias pessoas de jovens que
achavam por um momento que queria ser eu
serei exatamente eu dizia não tem que
ser e tem que ser você que você é
grandioso é só você acreditar o seu
potencial e lutar não importa as
diversidades as barreiras que nós
enfrentamos mas acreditar que está
dentro de nós e seguir adiante dá um
passo mas outro passo com vitória
obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]